In Marvel Studios'
Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania we get a close
look at the MCU's next big bad,
Kang the Conqueror.
And to help us break
down the design
behind this
multiversal miscreant,
I'm here with the director
of visual development
at Marvel Studios,
Andy Park, and concept
artist Constantine Sekeris.
Hi, guys.
- Hi.
Hi.
Let's dive in.
Kang is such an
iconic character,
and fans have been eagerly
awaiting his big screen debut.
So tell us where you started
with developing the conqueror
variant of this character?
Whenever we're tackling any
particular villain, when we're
trying to translate
comic into the MCU,
we always do a deep dive into
the comic books, of course,
starting off with Jack Kirby.
CONSTANTINE SEKERIS: Jack Kirby
just had this design sense
of just making
characters look iconic,
just very simple and bold.
ANDY PARK: So this is our chance
to come up with a classic look
that we see from the comic.
The purples, the greens,
the helmet, the blue visage.
One of the very
first inspiration
images that was given
to me was of Kang
just sitting on his throne.
He's called Kang the
Conqueror for a reason.
There's a certain status
that you see in him.
That's where we started.
The challenge in bringing
these classic comic book
costumes and looks into
the MCU is we're always
trying to bring a reality.
So with Kang, it was bringing
in the high-tech, futuristic
elements into his costume.
A big part of it was his helmet.
This helmet is really
unique from others we've seen.
Was there a certain
functionality
you needed to hit
with the design?
Whenever we
design helmets, it's
always such an important
element to the costume.
Because at the end
of the day, that's
what we're looking at, right?
In the original
Jack Kirby design,
he's got more of like
a sort of like toaster
square helmet that
started to become
a little bit not as functional.
We had played with adding a
clear face shield that allowed
then the actor to not
have something on his face
or cover up his face.
It was very important for Peyton
and the leadership of Marvel
to not lose his performance.
And even the question of,
will his face be blue,
or will it just be
Jonathan Majors?
We explored both, everything
from having blue lights emit
from the sides of the
helmet in towards the face,
projecting and giving
him a blue tinge,
to more the high-tech elements
of maybe kind of an energy
shield that kind of
conforms to the face
that gives him the blue look.
We explored a lot
of different textures,
different hues of blues.
In the end, it was like,
how much can we still see
Jonathan Majors' face
without seeing the sort
of like blue face shield.
So in the end, it was just
something very simple.
Simple, but so very effective.
Now what other details
did you focus on
to help craft the narrative
of Kang's backstory?
Yeah, the look that we were
going for is more the conqueror
Kang.
So he really has, like, this
regal kind of quality to him
with the cave, the robes that
hearken back to conquerors
of the past in human history.
But then we also wanted to
infuse suggestions of, this is
a Kang from the
future that has access
and developed high weaponry,
high sophisticated technology.
Even the way we
designed the cape
is a little different
than just a normal cape
as it's segmented.
So bringing the technology along
with the kind of more grounded,
rogue type of feel.
He's got this motif on his
face, these sort of like,
lines that is very iconic.
And so in the fabrics,
you see that a lot
with some of these
lines and textures that
give strength to the character.
Can you tell us more
about the design decisions
behind the lines on his face?
In this respect,
you have two sort
of like vertical
line designs, meaning
he's got the scars on his face.
And then when you do see him
with a sort of like blue face
guard, you've got tech lines.
ANDY PARK: A lot of
different kind of patterning
was done by the
different artists.
And then at the end of the
day, once we got that approved,
the makeup department led
by Alina Arroyo played
with the ideas of
doing different scars
on Jonathan Majors' face.
And it also alludes
to why he has
the lines in that blue
energy kind of mask.
But there's a story that maybe--
maybe we'll find out,
and maybe we won't.
We love a good cliffhanger.
Now your team has brought
such an awesome look for Kang.
What are you most proud of when
looking back at the process?
I'm very proud of how
the design looks on paper,
and then also how
it was translated.
So I'm going to have
to also give kudos
to the costume
department and props
for translating this
character in the real world.
I'm most proud of
my team of artists
and seeing that Kang was
pretty darn comic accurate,
I feel like this is a Kang
that I've been wanting to see,
the fans have been
wanting to see.
We stayed as true as we
could to the comic source.
Hopefully, we're not
letting any fans down.
I think it looks amazing.
Every time I see it, it
puts a smile on my face.
We're all smiling too.
Well, except for Kang.
He's not a smiler.
He's a conqueror.
Never mind.
Well, listen, Andy,
Constantine, thank you
so much for chatting with us.
Thanks, Langston.
Thank you.
And of course,
everyone, go experience
Marvel Studios'
Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania in theaters now.